on this episode I'm very serious in my
new office
you ask
this is
ask Gary B
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 220 of the
askgaryvee show this will be a trivia
question one day which episode was the
first episode in our new headquarters
and you know what we don't edit that
often like but like let's get some
b-roll from somebody step on till at
least even if it's like social media or
phone b-roll once you chop up a little
bit here show people a little bit around
the office I'm sure make dailyvee I'm
gonna kill me or we were only one
dailyvee behind right you're editing one
you're one your editing 57 yeah I'm fine
whoever but we I don't mean you this is
not a 57 s being edited so this will be
58 will be the new office got it okay
India what are your opening remarks to
our new office Wow India cursed let me
know it's awesome it's really amazing
the Rockies show a little bit real quick
I don't know how like it's got right
into the light I don't know how to go
Merriman I'm sorry you fancy you
overcast helps got it I see the garden
which is a clam looks like there's no
shell that's really exciting it's been a
great day
seems like all the Vayner peeps are very
happy makes me very happy people like
are you overwhelmed we happy and truth
is I'm not you know you know not to be
cool because that's not words coming
from I don't celebrate things as you
guys know like I don't see this as like
mu like I'm a I'm pumped for everybody
though people have space people are not
sitting in closets the cafeteria the
kitchens insane people got a proper
breakfast set down you know there's a
Seltzer machine is crazy you love it
right yeah so there's a lot of fun stuff
on this floor and a half a lot of people
up I love that people are walking by me
quite a bit which is exciting I get to
see a lot more people Vinnie
looking good let's go so yeah good day
super Punk and of zenned out actually my
energy is lower because I'm like focus
on of like getting everything right but
I'm excited by the show doing a
doubleheader today because we have
from million-dollar listings coming in a
little bit he's a cell Fredrick and he
said I got to be on as well so we'll see
him later but I didn't want the first
episode back to be a guest I wanted to
be a pure episode and so India doesn't
roll are you ready I'm ready to get into
the show mm-hmm killed it I love it look
at this spelling site
why don't I look up LA signed jersey
just like flapping around we need to get
this frame I need the hi Alex had a
great idea that I can hang the jerseys
from the rafters like they're retired so
alright already in yeah I'm ready okay
Roden Brodin yeah you tell me this
question you want to answer it okay
the universe version asks being a brand
new youtube channel what do you suggest
people do in order to accumulate more
subscribers and views anything
absolutely necessary or does it all just
come down to patience I want to answer
this because I thought this would bring
a lot of people value there's so many of
you that hear patience and then you just
think okay let me just continue to make
shows and content you're gonna wake up
four years later going from 85
subscribers to 219 and I don't want to
be on the hook for wasting your time you
have to understand and I talk about this
a lot and you guys hear it for me a lot
actually
a lot of the homies that are sitting out
there distribution distribution is the
game and so what you do when you have 85
you know people following your channel
or 200 or even 2,000 or even twenty
thousand or even 200,000 is you need to
understand that you need to keep
hustling for your awareness of course
and just so everybody knows this of
course your show has to be good you have
to continue make your craft strong you
have to continue to be interesting you
have to continue to bring value and
produce good content but you need people
to know about it and so I think one
reason I've always done well as I
understood that and so one of the great
ways to do this collaborations I think
if you've got a youtube channel you need
to basically reach out to I don't know
the other 7,000 people that are in your
genre and reach out to them and see if
you could bring them value right ours
you love UFC you decide to start a
channel you need to reach out to the
40,000 UFC channels and be like hey
No I'm in the network so I go to gyms I
can get you original content can you put
me on your show to bring me value for my
show when you have 44 viewers you can't
offer somebody has 400,000 viewers let's
trade you'll be on my show I'll be on
your show you get laughed out of the
room and people do that that's not the
way you're going to win that's not 5149
what you can offer something in return
what you can offer is access because
you're in those gyms with the original
content so maybe you can be doing on
location interviewing for that big UFC
thing and then you know and for yourself
too and then that person puts you on you
can offer money if you've got it that's
fine I mean whatever it is so it's about
distribution so collaborations with
other YouTube shows for sure social
media through and through creating
enormous amounts of content I've been
spending even more time paying attention
to how people are building organic
followings on instagram and hashtag
culture really works for the people that
are really patient you know it and I
have been flow with my hashtag work
dunka you do a good job with me on
musically you're like this is the one
that works like just you know I I would
even argue that I'm being lazy with my
hashtag work in Instagram for sure but
for a lot of you you have to go down
that route it really really really works
and then reverse engineering content
creation let me explain as we speak
right now
I have a video going viral it's called
August I made it so we could run it on
August 1st producing content that you
know has a chance of going somewhere
based on when you make it a Monday
morning rant that you post on Monday
morning making relevant content of
what's going on in the world either in
pop culture you know your thoughts on
what Miley Cyrus did on wrecking ball or
the Kanye and Taylor Swift Kim and
cotton you know Taylor Swift fight or or
the Olympic starting making content
that's relevant that gives it a little
bit of legs for shareability is very
important from the content creation look
there's only two things that content and
distribution and so whether it's
becoming a part of forums around UFC I
keep using yours you know like become a
member of forums become a member of
Facebook groups most of you are not
hustling distribution you're focusing on
the content and you think magically if
you keep patient and you keep doing it
something's going to happen nothing's
going to happen for four of you all time
once for forum you year something's
going to happen
a little motivational kid right the
Jamaican trainer kid then went viral
over the weekend somebody clearly posted
that video and it started the process
it's great content like that's clearly
content that's got a shot but he's been
putting out content for a little while
this is not his first rodeo and so yes
it happens right yes it happens but it's
far more interesting for you to take
control your distribution through
collaborations through proper hashtag
distribution on the Instagram world from
reaching out business Devyn reaching out
being part of forums and other internet
communities like Facebook groups to
become part of that community so when
you put out stuff people want to support
you I would tell you with Wine Library
TV I spent 20 minutes making the video
and I spent five hours creating the
distribution a day that's a great way to
end that because that's that's the
answer thank you okay hey Gary
congratulations on two years of a
successful show I just love it i watch
it all the time and get all sorts of
great advice from you my name is Shawna
I'm from hastin hustle comm and I just
wanted to ask you a quick question and
my question is when you're at the
beginning of your business or yes at any
time of your business um how do you know
how much risk is too much risk and when
to kind of pull back so I've got a
little again I hope no worries Thank You
Shawn I've got a really good answer for
this
I believe that risk is a very
interesting thing and I've got a pretty
good career with it and I would tell you
here's what mine looks like
I risk as much as I'm willing to
completely lose and I push it as far as
possible and that's always my model that
if all goes to zero on this move can i
still be breathing and stay alive
anything that would put me out of
business put me out of business and
people do that they borrow too much
money they dilute themselves in the
company that could make them lose
control from the board anything that
would put me at risk I I stay away from
so the the punchline is very simply I'm
willing to lose every penny other than
the first penny that I need to breathe
all of it I'm willing to lose you know
we do things here all the time
where I invest and buy things by
companies by AK you hire people and the
numbers always got to be if it goes to
dead zero will I still be alive to fight
another day
but I take it right to that edge and
really not like to like the penny
probably to the million dollars on a
hundred million dollar business but one
person you know just some little nest
egg but uh I think I'm stunned by people
that take risk that actually puts them
out
Floyd Mayweather doesn't take any risks
like that as a boxer that's why he's
undefeated
yeah Shh Shawn what's up Gary Shawn with
Denver here at the top of mountain evans
14,000 foot plus mountain here got a
question for you about breaking into new
accounts what's your recommendation do
you recommend starting high and then
going low or low and then going high
does it pin on the depend on the size of
the account small or large would love
your advice and insight thanks so much
um I always think it's a lot easier to
go lower than it is to go higher so if
again if you need an account more than
anything in the world to stay alive you
go and lo you do what you have to do to
stay alive but if you have the luxury of
I don't need this thousand bucks and but
I want this client I want to grow but I
don't need want the knee are two very
different things then I would go higher
you can always go down you can never go
up hey I want three thousand dollars a
month for this great no actually five
thousand not so easy hey I want three
thousand dollars a month for this yeah
alright 2500 so you know to me to me
it's just always better to go higher or
what I tend to do to be very frank with
you which is an interesting negotiating
move I tend to go the number I tend to
go it's 5:00 with Vayner when we started
it's $5,000 a month and people like I
don't want to pay we want to go 4,000
because maybe they thought I was going
higher and I said no it was a very
important thing to have that leverage to
not negotiate down and so we walked away
from things we didn't do things which
sucked at times but um it definitely
created a reputation in the marketplace
that I wasn't over evaluating stuff and
it was the number so to me it's higher
or the number um you know why do all
trades I go higher actually cut that
part
I don't want the guys that's me forward
Eric Eric asks when looking for a new
job do you think it's a bad idea to give
your boss a heads up before receiving
job offers so they can prepare for your
departure
I think that's every single per you know
that's a tough question a very small
question to me I wouldn't tell them I I
just think it's a survival the fittest
kind of thing like if you think it's a
vulnerability that you're not going to
be able to find it's like I just don't
that to me that's the risk thing I just
wouldn't do that because if they reacted
poorly even after five years thank you
very much thank you it's very nice
thanks Tyler
it made it you know I I I wouldn't do
that because that could get you to zero
and I you know don't forget they fire
you on the spot then you start taking a
job that you don't necessarily want just
to pay and now you're in a two-year
cycle of having crappy jet like it could
turn into a whirlwind now if your moral
compass is going off inside like crazy
and you can't sleep at night then do you
like I just think everybody's different
to me doing the right thing is always
the right thing if for you that's the
right thing then that's fine but but
make sure that's the right thing for you
not the way your mom sees the world or
your friends or or anybody else like it
that has to be your decision and and if
you're okay with the consequences I'm
okay with the consequences of speaking
the way I speak meaning I leave lots of
money on the table for cursing I'm okay
with that
you have to be okay with the
consequences I hate people that are
ideological and then when they have to
face the consequences they regret you
know it's the right thing what's the
name Eric it's the right thing to do
sounds good on paper if it's truly the
right thing to do for you then great
then do it but if it's not and then you
get fired and then you don't have
another job and who what you showed a
couple people you're a good guy like I
think a lot of people front so yeah
hmm expect me to say yeah say it yeah uh
it's easy for me to say though right
like like by the way I wouldn't do it
India and and people don't do it here
all the time like I don't I know two
people right now that are actively on
the way of going out and I don't know
mad at them I get it like they're like
you know I'm not paying their mortgage
I'm not feeding their family um you know
businesses businesses [ __ ] this is this
fire like like you know like right so I
don't know like I get it and like it's
like but I'm given the real answer here
and I think that everybody's different
but I definitely would not tell my boss
I would work on it get the job and then
I would go and I and I that's why I'm
not a hypocrite I never get mad when
people do that here I understand you
know I'm it's scary how many people
living in this crazy big city that we
can now see and that it's expensive and
they're on their own and their parents
couldn't help them and you know like
that's scary and then what I really get
sad is people done that here people quit
without having a job not for that reason
but for different reasons and then they
go into a crappy job because they're
just scared like they've held off for a
couple months but now they get really
scared me take anything and then they're
like it they're like two years step back
you know all right yeah
Kevin good hi what's up Gary Vee Kevin
without a key with obeah on Twitter here
and the Masai Mara Kenya's world famous
safari destination here were the Lions
my question this week is in a market
such as this even here everybody has a
smartphone huge smartphone penetration
twins with very early-stage social media
ad development and promotion what type
of content driven online business would
you advise to set up thanks very much by
Shannon I thought you know I don't know
the the market in Africa and Asia as
well as I give the rest of the world but
I'm very aware of the phone penetration
payment through phones lack of did you
see that that was amazing
something just dripped
from my pipe that's amazing
that was so cool um did you see that you
know about that I'm gonna fix it
eventually I would say that I would
reverse engineer the audience so what I
would do is I would spend months in the
Africa market figure out what people
want to buy and I would start an online
business that worked in the US or Europe
that's around psychology not just
because it was the US or Europe certain
things are tried-and-true human certain
things are contextual to the
neighborhood the country the cadence the
pulse the slang of a marketplace so I
would use my best of ability of
understanding what's human what's
innately human ecommerce you know buying
stuff water needs weather you know
whatever it may be whatever the markets
interested in and try to build around
that so to me it's understanding the
users with those phones what they're
doing I would look at what they're doing
now whether it's gaming or music
downloading or things of that nature and
then try to project what needs do they
have that they're doing in a traditional
way that the phone could solve and I
would look at the progressive phone
markets in Asia in the u.s. to see where
there are two or three years ahead I
think a lot of people looked at the US
market and and have tried to replicate
that in their marketing some have been
very successful and some have not and I
think some things are inherently us
centric and I think some things are
human centric and that's what you need
to decode and I think I've done well
with that and social networks some
things are just human based like if you
get a big enough group of people don't
drag other people into it snapchat
that's why those are easy for me to
predict great very serious show I wonder
if I'm gonna be serious when it's cloudy
like today and I wonder if the weather
is gonna dictate I'll be a funny data
point yeah question of the day what
should we ask what questions should we
ask India you asked a question thing um
question of the day do you think the
weather is going to affect Gary Smith Oh
what we're into
the jet season is coming you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
you